Israel is stepping up his security this
morning after a security guard was
stabbed at a Jerusalem bus station
demonstrators turned out in Bangladesh
an Indian and Indonesia after a weekend
of protests in the Middle East over
president Trump's recognizing Jerusalem
as Israel's capital Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu went to
France yesterday to visit France French
president and Manuel macro after they
met macron once again criticized the
u.s. decision on Jerusalem CBS Evening
News anchor Jeff Glor is in Paris where
he will interview the French president
later today
Jeff good morning John good morning to
you and Emmanuel macron has really
thrown himself into the world spotlight
now just seven months into his
presidency here in France trying to
carve out a leadership role in issues
like conflict in the Middle East as you
mentioned and climate change
last week McCrone criticized president
Trump's decision to recognize Jerusalem
as Israel's capital he repeated that
position standing next to Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu yesterday
McCrone said he told him that Yahoo
France remains committed to a two-state
solution and believes this is dangerous
for peace Netanyahu for his part
rejected that saying this is a reality
the world needs to accept the Paris is
the capital of France Jerusalem is the
capital of Israel it's been the capital
of Israel for 3,000 years it's been the
capital of the Jewish state for 70 years
we respect your history and your choices
and we know that his friends you respect
ours McCrone did denounce the attack on
that Israeli security guard that you
mentioned but he said that's happening
in part because president Trump is of
opposing security challenges by making
this big announcement on Jerusalem last
week Gail so Jeff before you go it's
been almost two years to this day
actually since world leaders signed that
Paris climate agreement so what does a
French president hope to accomplish with
this one planet summit
well he called for this one planet
summit in July and he's hosting about 50
world leaders here also some business
leaders as well the goal is to not only
create some public funding but he hopes
some private funding as well they're
trying to close a two point three
billion dollar funding hole for
developing countries to fight climate
change that gap was created when
President Trump announced the US would
withdraw from the Paris deal back in
June President Trump will not be at this
summit and at a rally on Friday he once
again criticized the deal is bad for the
US but said he is open to renegotiating
the terms McCrone has said that is not
an option these two share a very
interesting although brief history you
remember there was that long awkward
handshake that took place here in France
but they do get along well personally
and that's in part because they both our
political Outsiders who come from a
business background who are now part of
the establishment so we'll talk about
that with the president McCrone and much
more when we sit down with him Jeff Glor
I do remember that handshake reporting
from Paris with the Eiffel Tower right
behind you thank you Jeff you can see
Jeff's interview with the French
president tonight on the CBS Evening
News live from Paris